six one seven eight three zero forty
seven fifty is the number let's go to
our caller
why not the five zero two area code
let's try five zero two hello yeah
that's you who's this oh hey David how
are you I'm amar from Louisville
Kentucky
okay amar what's going on I'm just I'm
just calling to see if you're going to
politican this year you know I don't
have anything to announce yet with
regard to politican my my representative
is in touch with them my understanding
is that it's a completely new staff at
politican so there's a lot of sort of
starting from scratch and I don't have
an answer for you right now there's a
complicated scheduling thing where I'm
at another conference up until the day
before politican and so to do it I need
to fly they're not from Boston but from
this other conference so there's like
some logistical things and they've
really got to get sorted out soon
otherwise it's going to get too late in
the game but are you going cuz it's in
Nashville so I'm guessing it's close to
you in Kentucky yeah I'm going in my
first time going this year okay I wanted
to see you debate maybe like ben shapiro
cuz i watched the video when the first
time you talked to him and you kind of
turned into a robot yeah i thought that
was hilarious well maybe it'll happen
although my senses i don't even know
that ben shapiro is going as politican
announced to anybody who's going yet no
no I've just been watching you know
progressive voice and he's been covering
Sam Souter and steven crowder and all
that so I was wondering if you were
going got it ya know as soon as I have
something to announce I will and if it's
determined that I'm not going for
whatever reason I will also announce
that right now it's just a question mark
okay awesome thank you David all right
Ammar from Kentucky thank you for the
call